bonsoir pierre tattevin merci d'être
avec nous on entendait votre collègue
frédéric amené qui devaient débattre ce
soir il nous rejoindra peut-être en
cours de route dira en substance qu on
était la risée du monde est ce que vous
vous partagez ce diagnostic sévère tout
de même pour d'autres pays alors on a
mal démarré ça c'est sûr les premiers
jours ont pas été à la vitesse attendu
et puis les barrières qui avait été mise
dans les procédures font que c'était
compliqué mais la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'on a quand même très rapidement là
depuis quelques jours
ré augmenter le rythme avec une
simplification des procédures et on sent
une volonté d'aller beaucoup plus vite
donc on a quelques jours de retard au
démarrage ça c'est sûr mais il faut
savoir toute façon les vaccins n'étaient
pas disponibles dans l'union européenne
avant la toute fin du mois de décembre
donc on est passé par la catastrophe
il faut juste accéléré et et rectifier
le tir avec des procédures plus simples
pour la vaccination
on va on va regarder tout de même la
situation des vaccinations vous
relativiser mais il est tout de même des
chiffres ne sont pas glorieux je vous
propose de le découvrir sur ces images
un la france qui vaccinent 500 fois
moins tout de même que les mânes 516
personnes vaccinées en france au bout
d'une semaine contre 114 mille personnes
en italie près de deux cent trente neuf
mille en allemagne près d'un million au
royaume uni qui a lancé sa campagne de
vaccination en avance le mois dernier et
qui en précisent a pu quand même acheter
davantage de vaccins pfizer bio ntech si
on regarde dans le monde alors là on en
a carrément le tournis 4 millions et
demi de chinois vacciner 4,2 millions
d'américains huit cent mille personnes
en russie plus d'un million en israël
soit 13 % de la population est immunisée
on a beau relativiser tout de même
monsieur taste-vin
ça fait beaucoup de retard à ce qu'il
est rattrapable ce rtains vous en tant
qu infectiologues est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas inquiet tout de même
or quand vous dites ça fait beaucoup de
retard c'est vrai que les chiffres sont
assez effrayant mais en fait on a une
semaine de retard puisque les vaccins
sont disponibles depuis dimanche dernier
on a une semaine de retard donc il faut
qu'on a eu beaucoup plus vite il faut
qu'on vaccine des dizaines de milliers
de personnes puis des centaines de
milliers de personnes tous les jours
mais le matériel est en place les doses
sont disponibles les congélateurs sont
dans les différentes régions positionner
donc on peut rattraper tout ça je
partage votre constat pour dire qu'on
est loin derrière les autres
mais c'est une semaine de retard c'est
pas des mois c'est pas quelque chose dit
rattrapable enfin si on fait un calcul à
ce rythme là on y est encore comme
diraient certains dans dans quelques
mois voire dans quelques années le
patron des députés
les républicains damien abad plaide pour
qu à un nouveau débat sur la stratégie
vaccinale soit adoptée au parlement et
surtout ça vous concerne peut-être plus
en tant que médecin alléger les
procédures de consentement est ce que
c'est de cela qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui
finalement ceux qui ont envie de se
faire vacciner ben qu'ils y aillent et
qu'on arrête voilà de faire ce délai de
quatre jours qui complique les choses
absolument il ce délai de quatre jours
est quelque chose de vraiment un frein
pour que ça fonctionne bien et en plus
ça véhicule le message qu'ont à faire à
quelque chose de dangereux
alors que pour l'instant il n'y a
vraiment aucun signal qui suggèrent
qu'ils aient des effets indésirables
graves de manière fréquente avec ce
vaccin c'est certainement moins de 20
pour cent mille
on a des très bonnes informations sur
les premiers pays quand on fait beaucoup
sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas d'effets
indésirables g
donc il faut vraiment aller plus vite sa
chute je partage tout à fait cet avis là
c'est juste sur l'importance du retard
que je pense que on peut rattraper ça en
une ou deux semaines
si on fait bien les choses c'est vrai
que la france a sans doute été freinée
par le scepticisme légendaire des et des
français dans le domaine de la
vaccination
je vous propose de regarder le dernier
sondage en date 58 % c'est-à-dire six
français sur dix
veulent pas se faire vacciner soit plus
de 8 points par rapport au mois dernier
est ce que ce n'est pas ça aussi le
principal frein c'est vrai que les
autorités avancent un petit peu avec un
boulet la jambe si j'ose dire
c'est une des explications qu'ils ont
donnée pour expliquer tout tous les
freins qui avait au démarrage de cette
campagne il ya une semaine mais ce
n'était pas une bonne explication
probablement parce que c'est pas en
rajoutant tout c'est toutes ces
barrières à la vaccination qu'on va
pouvoir rassurer les gens il faut juste
qu'on le fasse et qu'on le fasse bien
avec un accompagnement médical des
personnes vaccinées naissant rajouter
des contraintes comme ce fameux délai de
4 jours entre d'autorisation enfin le
consentement donné par le patient et
l'administration du vaccin ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui nous freine
et qui a aucune justification
alors pour tenter peut-être de
convaincre les plus indécis et il y en a
comme on vient de le voir emmanuel
macron a proposé un collectif de
citoyens 35 citoyens français tirés au
sort
voilà qui se ruent trek scruterait cette
campagne de vaccination est ce que on
prend le problème dans le bon sens
qu'est ce que quel est l'avis du médecin
que vous êtes assez une bonne idée en
tout cas parce qu'on a vu pour les la
problématique de la vaccination
obligatoire de l'enfant le fait de faire
réfléchir et travailler ensemble des
citoyens des experts avaient permis
d'aboutir à quelque chose qui a été bien
acceptée après dans la population
générale
c'est une bonne idée ça aurait peut-être
pu être fait un petit peu plus tôt mais
en même temps le problème actuel c'est
pas tellement l'hésitation vaccinale
puisque même s'il y a que 50 % des gens
qui veulent se faire vacciner ça fait
quand même 30 millions de personnes donc
on a on a suffisamment de volontaires
pour se faire vacciner actuellement
c'est le problème actuellement c'est
plutôt de simplifier les procédures pour
pouvoir faire beaucoup de gens tous les
jours et et pouvoir avoir une population
de plus en plus protégés en 2008 à 5 1
lors de la 5e et on avait mis en place
ces vaccinodromes cgil
zone qui accueillait les populations est
ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû faire
finalement la même chose à ce que ça
serait souhaitable aujourd'hui selon
vous en tout cas on sent qu'on se dirige
vers ça va le fait d'avoir une offre de
vaccination à haut débit des endroits où
on puisse vacciner beaucoup de gens s'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner ce qui avait pas bien
marché en 2009 la cei le fait que les
médecins généralistes avaient pas été
bien impliquée dans le projet la
procédure de vaccination qui fait que
alors que c'est eux qui connaissent le
mieux la vaccination et qui font ça le
mieux en général il faut qu'il faut
impliquer la même si on a des grands
centres de vaccination qui sont ouverts
il faudra qu'on travaille avec les
médecins généralistes qui connaissent
les patients et qui connaissent bien la
vaccination mais c'est peut-être 20
pardonnez moi mais ça ça fait des
semaines déjà qu'on en parle
comment ça se fait finalement que ça
n'ait pas été mis en place que les
médecins ne soit pas déjà au courant
n'implique pas déjà les patients
concernés selon vous l'histoire des
centres de vaccination sa us a eu
vraiment le retour qu'on en avait eu en
2009 était une des raisons pour
lesquelles l'hésitation vaccinale a
autant augmenter à l'époque non à
l'époque ça avait été une mauvaise à
mauvais choix et ça nous a pas aidés
cette fois ci ce qui est différent c'est
d'abord on a beau l'urgence est beaucoup
plus net pour tout le monde il faut
qu'on vaccine plusieurs dizaines de
millions de personnes avant l'été ça
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
et l'autre chose c'est que la population
a beaucoup plus conscience de la gravité
de la maladie puisque tout le monde a vu
autour de soi des gens souffrir de la
colline 19 tout le monde a vu ce que ça
a eu comme impact sur la société dont je
pense que les gens sont plus prêts
maintenant à ces grands centres de
vaccination et qu'on doit pouvoir les
mettre en place
mais encore une fois pour les jours qui
viennent là c'est pas ça dont on a le
plus besoin c'est d'avoir des des
schémas de vaccination qui soit rapide
rapide et facile à mettre en place dans
les hôpitaux pour qu'on puisse aller
rapidement aux dizaines de milliers de
personnes à vacciner dont on a besoin
c'était attendu à l'information dont on
parlait tout à l'heure
salle du spi galles
die zeit rapporté d'ailleurs par le
français valeur actuelle la france qui
aurait refusé une offre de plus de 500
millions de doses du vaccin pedder bio
ntech l union européenne pour
privilégier en faire du protectionnisme
ça se fait dans tous les pays pour
privilégier sanofi sauf que sanofi n'est
pas du tout prêt à l'heure actuelle est
ce que c'est de cela qu'on souffre des
lobbys peut-être des laboratoires et de
l'absence de ce vaccin français qui fait
cruellement défaut aujourd'hui
non je crois vraiment là c'est un peu
hors sujet parce que finalement on a les
millions de doses disponibles à pour
vacciner des patients dès ce mois de
janvier
donc c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas les
vaccins qu'on vaccine pas c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas encore activé le système
de vaccination et j'ai jamais entendue
dans les discussions avec les collègues
des gens dire attendez on va attendre
d'avoir un vaccin française c'est
vraiment pas le sujet ils sont déjà au
nombre de vaccins puisqu'ils vont
beaucoup plus vite que nous pour
vacciner ils sont déjà à se demander
voilà où sont les vaccins si il y aura
des doses nécessaires et ça ne semble
pas être le cas d'où la grogne dans le
pays
la distribution des doses du vaccin
pfizer dans l'union européenne s'est
fait au prorata de la population donc on
en a autant par habitant de l'allemagne
où ils sont en manque parce qu'ils ont
été beaucoup plus vite et nous c'est pas
le problème du manque c'est pas parce
qu'on attend le vaccin sanofi c'est
juste qu'on ne s'est pas mis en route au
bon rythme la semaine dernière que le
vaccin était disponible alors on fait
tout ce que même constat et laisser les
chiffres que nous avait montré on n'a
pas démarré comme il fallait
vous êtes optimiste pour l'avenir on est
on est attentif 1 mais les bonnes
nouvelles c'est qu'au bout de trois
jours quand ça a râlé quand les gens ont
dit ça va pas assez vite il faut changer
le gouvernement a vraiment changé de
braquet est là ensemble et dès ce début
de semaine vous allez voir je pense que
c'est vrai on va voir les chiffres mais
plusieurs milliers ou dizaines de
milliers de personnes vont être vaccinés
tous les jours versus les 500 de la
semaine dernière donc on sent qu'il ya
eu une prise en compte de la grogne un
peu général et notamment des
scientifiques et que le gouvernement a
changé de stratégie et passe à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus rapide après on
est vigilant on va surveiller on va
regarder les compteurs et on va voir
on rattrape le retard qu'on a pris cette
première semaine merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous pierre tattevin